cette initiative de l'association les
enfants de don quichotte pour
sensibiliser les parisiens à la galère
des sdf et bien ils ont installé une
centaine de tentes de part et d'autre du
canal saint-martin et proposent aux
passants et bien de passer une nuit
simplement une seule sous la tente pour
comprendre ce que vivent au quotidien
les sans domicile fixe elle lors d
arnaud et pierre pachoud un campement de
sdf en plein coeur de paris sous l'oeil
étonné des touristes au total une
centaine de tentes installées pour les
sans abri mais également pour les bien
logés pour c'était l'occasion de
partager pendant une nuit ou deux des
conditions de vie difficiles
je me doutais très bien que ce n'était
pas évident la vie à la rue que le
regard des passants mais pas évident non
plus quand on était dehors et que les
gens nous regardaient de haut en bas on
le sait mais voilà on peut le vivre un
tout petit peu sans vouloir jouer les
sdf pour autant ce n'était pas le but de
cette nuit ils étaient près de 80 dormir
sous une tente dont un tiers de sdf bien
logées ou sans abri de monde qui
normalement se croisent et qui sur ce
qu'elle apprenne à se connaître on voit
qu'on n'est pas tout seul quand même
qu'il ya des gens qui comprennent ce que
c'est l'avis de d'or j'espère ou alors
augustin est à l'initiative de ce projet
choquée de voir ton de sdf délaissé il
lance un appel à tous les citoyens
je pense que sur 56 millions d'habitants
on peut être vraiment plusieurs milliers
à camper par solidarité et donné deux
mi-temps pour les sdf
méthode pour contesté et pour demander à
l'état
exiger de l'état ce qui s'occupe de ces
gens moi mardi l'association doit
rencontrer la ministre déléguée à la
cohésion sociale catherine vautrin les
organisateurs prévoient pour l'instant
de rester 3 nous